[Musique]
du vendredi tout à fait spécial de fin
de saison bien sûr avec Claire Bolduc
qui est avec nous avec Rodolphe fusny
avec Mona Lisa Prosper et avec Jacques
letourneaux nos membres du CA on va
avoir un quiz dans quelques instants
vous présenter mais d'abord qu'est-ce
qu'on doit lire qu'est-ce qu'on doit
voir qu'est-ce qu'on doit écouter
qu'est-ce que vous proposez puis on va
commencer tout de suite avec l'air
alors moi je vous propose la lecture ou
la relecture du rapport du GIEC sur les
changements climatiques
dans le fond il y a on peut commencer
par les sommaires pour les décideurs le
sommaire pour ceux qui font les
politiques publiques c'est Jérôme Duprat
un chercheur a du coup qui est aussi
bassiste chez les Cowboys Fringants qui
est venu présenter une conférence et qui
nous a rappelé que tout est écrit dans
ses rapports-là qui sont vraiment les
moyens sont vraiment à notre portée on
peut agir mais la première chose qui est
dite c'est que il faut vraiment qu'il y
ait une vision concertée et qu'on
s'enligne tout le monde à tous les
niveaux international comme national
comme municipal pour agir dans le même
sens alors merci le message est passé
vraiment policiers économique l'Égypte
j'en ai pas trouvé donc mais je vous
suggère quand même quelque chose de pas
lourd passer pas écrit par une
économiste c'est écrit par un écrivain
mais qui est aussi quelqu'un engagé avec
l'attaque Québec depuis plusieurs années
c'est sur la fin du néolibéralisme et
c'est très intéressant parce que société
non non mais c'est quand la fin du néant
nous explique que nous sommes non mais
il nous explique que nous sommes dans
une période où le néolibéralisme tire à
sa fin parce que le néolibéralisme tel
la mondialisation on pense de plus en
plus local le néolibéralisme des
engagements de l'État on refineance et
on veut refinancer de plus en plus les
services publics nous sommes de donc le
retour de l'État nation close
veillancourt la fin du néolibéralisme
éco-société Mona Lisa alors moi j'ai été
un peu plus léger c'est un podcast par
deux étudiants de l'Université de
Sherbrooke qui s'appelle cosser seul
économie voilà et donc une belle
vulgarisation du sujet par deux
étudiants au bac et en sciences
économique donc je me suis dit que je
vais suggérer ça tout le monde qui plus
s'initier
Rodolphe je vais vous recommander un
balado qui s'appelle question d'intérêt
d'un animateur qui s'appelle gérald
Fillion qui a fait et je dois dire que
c'était très intéressant les anciens
ministres des Finances du Québec moi
j'ai beaucoup aimé écouter ces balades
donc je vous invite tous à les écouter
si ce n'est déjà fait donc de les
réécouter si vous l'avez déjà fait ok
c'est une bonne suggestions on arrête là
c'est parfait quiz il nous reste 5
minutes pour faire notre quiz et là
j'espère que vous allez être bon alors
dès que vous avez la réponse puis même
claire là
on se gêne pas pour relever la main ou
par là même trier la réponse il faut
c'est bon première question combien
peut-on pour un litre de lait de pour ça
en ce moment au Québec 99 2 litres 2 1
litre 2% 2 dollars 20 99 claire
le litre est à 2$
c'était pas loin je trouve deux dollars
20 aussi je prends un demi point quand
même non c'est point Ville-Marie Abitibi
2 dollars le minimum et de
je me trompe toujours 2 dollars 17 pour
ce qui est du maximum 15 septembre
quel secteur d'activité a connu
d'importantes compression au début
d'année 2023 aux États-Unis technologie
technologie Mona Lisa excellent environ
150 000 pertes d'emploi 85000 en janvier
seulement très bon un
les gars les gars
quel oiseau pierre fait du Gabin
chassait-il l'automne dernier
délai ok on va s'entendre
la hausse de salaire que les députés se
sont votés à Québec
30 % le salaire annuel de base des élus
qui est passé donc de 1000 à 131 766 il
s'agit bien sûr autre chose en fonction
des fonctions parlementaires combien
coûterait l'enfouissement de toutes les
lignes d'Hydro-Québec à la grandeur du
milliard
100 milliard 100 milliards bravo
fantastique vous avez toute la nuit
90 milliards
c'est pour ça n'est-ce pas ça va coûter
plus
cher si ça se fait alors c'est un
chiffre en passant qui vient d'Éric
Martel le PDG à l'époque d'Hydro-Québec
100 milliards en 2019 et c'est un
chiffre également qui a été repris par
François Legault François Legault qui a
23 fois j'étais 30 %. c'est vrai
vous avez raison mais je vous donne pas
de points quand même alors Rodolphe un
point jusqu'à maintenant nos deux points
2 points et les Ouija qu'à un Rodolphe 2
Mona Lisa à deux éclaire à 1 ou 2
3 ça va bien combien y a-t-il eu de
mouture du troisième lien jusqu'à
maintenant 5 et ben Jacques fantastique
c'est un guest
[Rires]
comme ça excellent
Jacques
juin 2019 un tunnel de 6 km et demi mai
2021 un tunnel de 8,3 km avril 2022
petit tunnels avril 2023 deux tunnels un
pour le transport en commun et un étage
étagé pour des véhicules et avril 2023
finalement pas d'auto juste du transport
collectif mais ça demeure à être défini
dans quel pays se tiendra la cop28 la
conférence sur le climat du 30 novembre
au 12 décembre cette année
Dubaï
c'est pas Dubaï
Emira Arabe Unis
par ailleurs PDG de la compagnie
nationale du pétrole et ministre de
l'Industrie c'est pratique on fait les
deux ensemble
je garde le poids
des fonctionnaires canadiens sur leur
cellulaire de fonctions
visite en mars le président américain a
dit dans son discours qu'il aime toutes
les équipes de hockey au Canada sauf une
chance
et une dernière après combien d'années
des jardins a-t-il abandonné son livret
de caisse
je lui donne bravo ça donne combien ça
en régie combien on a pour nos
différents
concours quand même Jacques II Monalisa
2 Rodolphe
merci merci à vous quatre merci beaucoup
d'avoir participé tout à fait spécial
bon été puis on se retrouve à l'automne
à la rentrée pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI